could an alien species consists of only
thought or energy nothing we would
recognize as body or mass I don't see
why not
except by the way mass is energy energy
is mass so I can imagine an alien
species that is energy I can imagine it
make a pound of energy I can allow my
brain to accept the possibility of it I
don't know how to portray it I don't
know how to I don't know right but since
neither energy are equivalent I think
we're good here okay a problem is energy
it's hard to create form out of energy
when energy becomes matter you can make
molecules and things and objects and
brains and this sort of thing without it
it's amorphous it might be harder to
make amorphous life than material life
expended could get could you eat it
though could you eat a being made of
energy okay acceleration actually since
the only point of humans eating is to
give ourselves energy and nourishment
yes if there is an alien that is made of
energy you wouldn't have to eat it you
just have to absorb it okay great